hi this is James Franco and I'm here
with film courage calm I'm talking to
Karen worden and David Brannon we're
gonna talk about this Palo Alto story's
campaign on IndieGoGo thank you so much
for listening and I know you've been I
think quoted as saying that Art of
Elysium which is the charity that you're
connected to with these projects saved
your life are you able to touch on how
that happened my weight my just meeting
a little more sane a little more humble
I you know I I wasn't dying or anything
but I I was in a spot where I I was very
unhappy and and I'm you know we're
talking about six or seven years ago and
I am looking for you know it was a turn
when my life I guess I was looking for
ways to make life seem worthwhile or
fulfilling and one of the things I found
at that time was our Belizean and it
gave me the opportunities to just be
back and sometimes we just sometimes we
don't even know how to give back and
this had everything that I wanted you
know it had you know there were people
and children in need and this was a
program that I would you be saying that
I that I knew you know as far as acting
or you know working with others or
directing and and I could use those
skills with the children so it was it
was everything I wanted